le ministre de la Santé Christian dubéte
avec nous ce soir bonsoir Monsieur Dubé
vous êtes un homme qui aimait
l'efficacité qui a mis avoir des
résultats donc combien de temps vous
vous donnez pour que les patients
puissent voir vraiment une amélioration
tangible dans les urgences
quelques semaines je voudrais qu'on voit
des premiers signes d'amélioration
d'ailleurs moi j'envoie quelques-uns des
jeunes dans la baisse de nos de nos
personnes qui sont en attente d'une
classe par exemple dans un ch CD ou pour
libérer des urgences mais je vous dirais
que ça va prendre quelques semaines mais
ça se fera pas ça se fera pas partout
pareil des endroits il y a des hôpitaux
il y a des établissements où ça va déjà
mieux on est en train d'essayer
d'implanter des nouvelles pratiques sur
plusieurs mesures c'est sûr que des
endroits qui sont un petit peu plus en
retard que d'autres mais globalement je
pense que dans les prochaines semaines
on devrait voir pour être capable de
passer à travers la période qui s'en
vient
prochaines semaines c'est quoi c'est
moins d'un mois ou plus
on va le voir dans les prochaines
semaines donc c'est moins d'un mois mais
comme je vous dis globalement on va
avoir beaucoup de volume additionnels
dans nos urgences à cause de des fêtes
qui s'enviennent à cause de l'hiver il y
a toutes sortes de raisons mais
j'aimerais ça qu'on voit des
améliorations à très très courte parce
que l'heure est
grave on redit sont très inquiets perdre
un point de rupture et vous ont écrit
une lettre dans laquelle ils disent que
les urgences sont condamnés à sacrifier
leur mission première soit de traiter en
temps opportun les personnes dont la
situation est instable potentiellement
mortelle comment vous recevez ça je les
rencontre demain matin c'est drôle parce
que il m'avait demandé il y a quelques
semaines des rencontres c'était avant
tout ce débat là j'ai accepté je les
vois demain matin puis je vous dirais
que ce qui me préoccupe beaucoup c'est
que eux sont préoccupés par la qualité
du service qu'il donne ils sont très
préoccupés par ça puis ce sont des
professionnels alors mon rôle à moi
c'est pas de soigner les gens mais c'est
de leur donner des outils pour qu'il
soit capable de bien faire leur travail
alors c'est pour ça que je vais faire
toujours aux meilleurs pratiques parce
que il y a plusieurs hôpitaux qui vivent
les mêmes problèmes et qui réagissent
mieux on se dit toujours c'est qui nos
meilleurs trucs qui ont pu prendre
exemple pour améliorer ça partout pareil
pour les enfants c'est là qu'on a
beaucoup de c'est là qu'on a beaucoup de
problèmes à cause des nouveaux virus
respiratoires puis ils se débrouillent
quand même relativement bien dans ces
circonstances là alors c'est un peu ce
que je dis au chef des urgences que je
vais voir demain à Québec on vient de
mettre trois mesures très claires qu'on
veut implanter partout et on va vous
donner les outils pour diminuer cette
pression là sur vos horaires ensemble
les trois mesures la première prioriser
le 81-1 est-ce que c'est le même 81
qu'on connaît depuis des années où c'est
une version améliorée de la chance on
améliore le 81 mais on veut que ça soit
simple pour les gens quand ils savent
pas où appeler il faut qu'il appelle le
8 au lieu de se rendre à l'urgence
parce que dans nos mesures c'est
d'éviter que les gens quand ils n'ont
pas à aller aux urgences alors là les
gens commencent vous avez le guichet
d'accès on a parlé beaucoup dans les
derniers mois on appelle 81 si vous
savez pas quoi faire appelez ou 8 heures
les gens vont vous rediriger notamment
pour les pour les enfants il y a plus de
monde pour répondre au téléphone en plus
de monde puis et on travaille mieux avec
service Québec on avait des téléphones
qui étaient disponibles sur service
Québec je les ramène au 81 pour qu'ils
viennent nous aider pendant cette
période là en ce moment-là les cliniques
avec des infirmières praticiennes
spécialisées ça ça veut dire les
cliniques sans médecin
vous avez dit en conférence de presse
cet après-midi ça fait longtemps qu'on
aurait pu mettre ça en place qu'est-ce
qui coincé
il y a beaucoup de culture de c'est pas
les médecins qui l'empêchaient mais il y
a une réflexe de dire on a toujours
travaillé comme ça ben j'aimerais ça
revoir le travail de l'infirmière mais à
Québec le jeune clinique d'infirmière
spécialisée qui fonctionne de façon
autonome ça fonctionne très bien alors
quand les professionnels dans la cellule
de crise ont dit mais pourquoi qu'on le
fait pas à Montréal ben je dis ok
allons-y alors il y a une question de
culture puis je pense que pour pas avoir
peur de d'utiliser une crise des fois
pour changer les choses sont de vues
avec la covid on a pu avancer dans le
décloisonnement des professions donc un
changement de culture a opéré ici en
même temps tout à fait troisième mesure
on peut résumer
les un peu plus les lits d'hôpitaux pour
amener les gens à la maison en attente
d'une place en hébergement comment vous
pouvez rassurer les gens qui vont être
bien suivis bien soignés alors qu'on a
de la difficulté à le faire en hôpital
et qu'il manque de personnel la première
façon de les rassurer c'est que ça se
fait déjà dans certains endroits encore
une fois et ça se fait très bien par
exemple dans les Laurentides c'est une
orientation qui avait été donnée par le
ministère en 2017 croyez-le ou non c'est
pas d'hier mais c'est pas tout le monde
qui l'a appliqué et ceux qui l'ont
appliqué comme dans les Laurentides et
on dit ça fonctionne très bien ils ont
été capables de baisser la chalandage
aux urgences dans leurs hôpitaux parce
que les gens sortent plus rapidement on
est capable de libérer des lits qui
servent aux urgences donc encore une
fois ça s'est fait de façon sécuritaire
je redis souvent la même chose une
question d'implantation il y en a une
bonne pratique qu'ils envoient en soins
à domicile puis avec l'arrivée de Sonia
Bélanger qui est la nouvelle ministre
qui est celle que implanter les soins à
domicile avec le docteur Deschênes dans
Verdun c'est un très beau succès avec ce
qu'on demande Sonia c'est de donner les
outils pour ce qui est en train de se
faire à la naudière puisse être implanté
par tout donc vous regardez les
histoires
qui ça y est de vous en inspirer pour
les mettre ailleurs ça c'est pour le
Grand Montréal quand on parle de la
cellule de crise on entend des régions
crier dire à quand notre tour ils ont
raison parce qu'on a un problème partout
mais je vous dirais que nos indicateurs
nous disaient que c'est encore plus
grave à Montréal fait que je voulais
m'entendre rapidement dans les premières
semaines pour régler mon Réal avoir une
indication mais les retrouver en mesure
dont on parle ce soir Madame Lacroix ils
peuvent les implanter à Québec ou en
Outaouais
c'est exactement ce qu'on va faire mais
là je voulais au moins me concentrer
pour sortir pour encourager autant les
patients que nos professionnels qui sont
pas tout seul en ce moment c'est ça il
faut redonner de l'espoir au réseau
qu'on va trouver des solutions ils sont
pas tout seul eux ils sentent vraiment
seuls en ce moment trouve qu'il manque
de monde pénurie de personnel ça c'est
le gros problème dans le système de la
santé vous êtes le premier à savoir
aussi on a présenté un reportage hier
qui parlait des
médecins qui ont été formés à l'étranger
qu'on retrouve très très peu chez nous
au Québec pour les médecins de famille
par exemple alors que dans d'autres
provinces on va les recruter on va les
chercher
est-ce que vous vous engagez à leur
faciliter la vie à faire en sorte qu'il
décroche des contrats la réponse c'est
oui puis une des personnes à qui j'ai
énormément confiance depuis les deux
années que je suis à la santé c'est le
docteur Gaudreault qui est le président
du Collège des médecins et lui sur la
crise justement pour m'aider dans ces
mesures là parce que il m'a beaucoup
aidé avec le décloisonnement des
professions et là il y a fait une sortie
récemment justement comment faciliter la
part de médecin étranger pour justement
penser à travers la paperasse de tout ça
donc résultat qu'on le fasse c'est des
mesures que vous l'avez dit que sont
faites partout alors j'ai demandé au
Docteur Godreau spécifiquement de venir
nous aider comment on peut faire arriver
ça plus rapidement bon alors on va
regarder ça en terminant on a appris cet
après-midi que ni Québec solidaire ni le
Parti Québécois ne vont siéger à
l'Assemblée nationale parce qu'ils n'ont
pas prêté serment au roi Charles III
comment vous réagissez à ça nous aider
dans les urgences en attendant je sais
pas là
mais croyez-vous qu'il devrait avoir
leur place à la nationalité
en ce moment là je vais laisser ça à mon
parti au Premier ministre au leader de
régler ces choses là moi j'ai hâte de
recommencer à travailler ça je veux vous
dire ça parce qu'on a beaucoup de
projets de loi j'ai une très belle
collaboration avec Vincent Marissal qui
était critique à la santé donc j'espère
que ces choses-là vont se régler dans
les prochaines semaines merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup madame